en art mari philippe gassot en direct de
villacoublay puis de retour philippe
gassot nous voyons nous vous écoutons
parler et bien côté je crois que nous
sommes à l'antenne nous avons quelques
petites difficultés techniques ce qui
est bien normal compte tenu du
déplacement de journalistes qui lie à
autour de nous des mâts et des voitures
de transmission gt il y à quelques
secondes avec jean paul kauffmann jean
paul kauffmann qui semble-t-il réagit
bien à sa libération
joëlle kauffmann me disait il ya
quelques secondes je le retrouve
exactement comme je lé qui tu es j'ai eu
l'occasion de converser avec lui au
milieu d'une meute de journalistes quand
même et je vous propose de l'entendre
l'extérieur et dans toutes les pensées
ou il nous a dit cela très heureux au
nom de leur profession
pensez à vous et tu laisses moi tous les
jours dans nos journaux vous étiez
présent ainsi que beaucoup de mercy
remercions merci enfin bon quand on a dû
virer au bout de trois ans le calvaire
est terminé
nous remercions principe le gouvernement
français boit tout ce qu'il a pu et tous
les gens qui nous ont aidés vous pouvez
nous dire quels ont été les
circonstances de votre libération
justement au nom jarry vous savez je
suis comme vous l'avez su qu'on allait
vous alliez être libéré il y avait des
rumeurs
enfin je suis moi j'ai connu je suis
mardi matin et vous jean paul et bien
moi je les a pris
à 11 heures du matin hier enfin il y a
une chose qu'il faut pas oublier bon et
vrai cocon doit redire inlassablement
c'est un jour est formidable bien sûr
aujourd'hui mais
c'est quand même un jour qui est qui qui
reste assombri par le fait que nous ne
sommes que trois et que moi j'ai été
enlevé le 22 mai 1985 avec un homme qui
s'appelait michel seurat j'étais avec
lui pendant de longs mois et puis nous
l'avons vu s'éteindre peu à peu et gg
d'une certaine manière j'ai un peu honte
aujourd'hui la d'être la fab on ne
jouons pas sur les mots mais sa demande
et un marcel carton et marcel fontaine
on a vu michel seurat lutter avec avec
avec avec des espoirs il ya aussi j'veux
dire avec avec avec noblesse là il
il s'exprimait pas beaucoup il se voyait
mourir il a voulu vivre ccc c'est
quelque chose d'affreux et puis
aujourd'hui d'abord et avant tout ma
pensée va à marie sera sa femme je ne
sais pas où elle est actuellement mais
et à ses deux filles
et c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure
à son oncle michel au début me disait tu
sais moi j'agis beaucoup de mal
personnellement au début les premières
semaines fut reçue en furent affreuse
michel lui était tout à fait bon il
prenait la situation avec une certaine
philosophie prenait des notes il
écrivait cetera
et puis enfin il disait moi tu sais je
suis prêt à attendre trois ans pour
revoir mes deux filles jeudi a mis trois
ans mais je me suis fou tu te rends
compte trois ans et puis bon et cédric
heures qui a disparu nous l'avons vu
pour la dernière fois le 28 décembre
1985 il était n'arrivait plus à tenir
debout il a été transféré dans un
endroit côté de tenue de nos cellules de
notre cellule
et puis on l'a entendu pendant encore
quelques jours il plus effroyablement il
avait faussé ccc c'est quelque chose de
terrible
on était tous les quatre ensemble va
demander à marcel carton à marcel
fontaine là ils ont vus quotidiennement
là et qui luttait puis il savait qu'il a
failli c'est parce qu'il avait
exactement mais ils savaient qu'ils
allaient que c'était
quick c'était désespère il aurait pu et
moi je prends fait il aurait pu mourir
auprès des siens et puis il est mort
tout seul c'est quelque chose d'affreux
ça je ne peux pas l'oublier et mai et la
deuxième chose aussi qu'il faut pas
oublier c'est que nous nous sommes
libérés mais il ya d'autres otages à
l'effacement appelle les otages
occidentaux ya ces américains et
britanniques
cc allemand cet allemand la bon il ya
thierry weight bon ccc il faut pas les
oublier cela bon on sait on est contents
il n'y a plus de taches français mais il
reste les autres et puis je vous prie de
croire que bon de savoir que qu'en ce
moment même la dent il ya des des otages
l'acquis qui mène cette vie de cauchemar
la de mauvais rêves que nous avons vécue
quotidiennement nous ont habitués à
vingt-quatre heures sur vingt-quatre
enfin bon enfant
quelles conditions oui nous étions
enchaîné depuis le mois de février l'an
dernier après les là l'intervention
enfin american l'aller les bateaux là
qui s'approchait des côtes
ç'a eu pour résultat qu'on lui supprime
la radio premièrement et ensuite qu'on
nous pose des chaînes et puis bon on a
eu des mois j'ai eu les chaînes aux
pieds ainsi mes compagnons du pilier le
mois de février l'an dernier bon bah on
s'y habitue 1 on revient pas de des
camps de la mort il faut pas exagérer
non plus mais c'est ça a été on en a
survécu